mais arrivé deux fois l'or lui revient
du maroc qui est magnifique normalement
vous ai connu un beau week-end bosser il
est avec qui quitte à moi ouais il était
avec un ami et un ami proche
c'est-à-dire
et la vie normale saine et 71 ou pas du
tout mon nom n'a pas une
vraie mais l'autre ah oui un très
mauvais mais l'autre ce tonneau me
honnet louis tout court mais tous
d'accord mais comme cyril est ami avec
toi voilà c'est ça un troupeau non pas
du tout on aurait pu croire à la piscine
tous les trois étaient à la série ouais
d'autant que j'ai rencontré là bas au
bord de la piscine une star bat comme
moi qui était venu en vacances
ah pardon ma part il vous labarthe est à
venir c'est ce qu'il a fait c'était le
patrick sébastien du portugal
c'est vrai au foot au
procès ah oui et je lui parle un peu
parce qu'il est à côté la piscine plage
parlée oise alors vous draguer un peu un
drag et non merci je drague pas à pas du
tout non non il avait dragué le patrick
sébastien lui porte une petite preuve
parce que pour vous à bout des gars vous
avez su que c'est pas sexy du tout
edenred à côté il avait
été de 3,1 à côté alors droite d'à côté
donc sur la conversation comme ça paraît
un petit peu et alors qu'il était tout
ça sinon il qu'avec 1
est
[Rires]
ce qui n'était qu'un avion l'année
prochaine accompagné un ami proche il
était accompagné non elle a mis une amie
proche des transats et des proches
des proches mais quelqu'un tombe en
panne
on a mis paris les gens si la vie voilà
nana nous plaît je le respectais de
l'année marie stricte et si vous voulez
que votre anniversaire pendant deux
semaines
[Musique]
mais c'est
bon quoi s'occuper de vous dans un an
pour
l'instant nos solutions se voit là et
après le besnerais dans la vie mais je
suis animateur la star portugal alors et
par les français quelques résidences non
il parlait français oui absolument avec
un petit accent un léger accent charmant
wen jibao moi même me connaissez vous
et
je dis moi même je suis animateur star
en france bah du coup qu'est ce que font
deux animateurs côte d'ivoire ils se
bouffent le cul mais non
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui pour moi ne s'est pas
rassuré parce que cet arrêt est ce qu'on
sait déjà bouffé le cul non et pourtant
cet animateur voyez pas vous aussi vous
êtes apprentis animateur
pour l'âme
107 ans bonjour a parlé on a déjeuné
ensemble bien sûr c'est vrai oui quand
même pas au bord des piscines non alors
il y avait une belle traîne
la patte et de l'accueil sont très vive
reconnaissance ah oui ah oui ah oui mais
oui oui oui non même que des centaines
avaient vu quelque chose mais si même
pas du tout mais si d'abord un pas du
tout dit ou pensé vraiment il est arrivé
il était avec un ami un proche ouais
mais l'étoile hôte à leurs tares de
rémission à l'arrivée
mais c'est en couple bah oui mais non il
ya 700 appareils sait ce qu'il veut et
je connais pas dire que y'a rien de
sérieux
par son ami et okur
kanak a rien de sérieux je vais me tuer
non non si si quand même nom il était
c'était lui amis proches bah oui oui
les places je l'emmène oui
mais il sort il sort sa tête
donc on est parti ensemble et le russe
un ami et l'autre qui tenait les
chandelles
parce qu'ils sont pas retirés d'un
grammy non mais sans déconner et l'autre
ami qu'est ce qu'ils ont baptisé vous
connaissez ces mots c'est mon associé
non
et oui vous avez bien
s'aligner ou busquets
et oui là n'ont rien et avec le
portugais non ça répond guillaume et a
répondu ne veut pas d'où ça c'est ça
c'était des rendez que des rencontres de
boulot de business business moi j'arrête
jamais caché là bas d'accord et sa
profonde unité petit business et
business que vous avez fait que
portugais mais on discute pour des cow
prod ou peut-être si le portugal est
intéressé parce que je vous adore ouais
moi demain le ccaf appelle chaîne au
maroc
et tout ça merci très bien bivouac et
bien c'est dit ajouté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà des mois qu'il
parlait pas très bien français
voilà en tout cas très belle histoire
l'euro n'était pas la guitare abah
abah abah rabat tout est neuf et un
continent sans grille
c'est pour ça que
mes cadeaux comme elodie nom d'une fleur
je peux voir pendant au moins trois
semaines
à merci j'aurais pu mais une pommette
quoi cogniaux parce que vous adore aussi
évidemment sur bien sûr ah non mais
alors là c'est gentil il les appelle ses
choux les deux coanimateurs non mignon
un premier contact on aurait tous les
deux là bas pour des kings guerre civile
toiture mais aussi au maroc à marrakech
où tu veux y aller moi quand seulement
baby gym j'adore non mais je n'avais pas
prévu de venir
j'ai l'intention d'y aller avec un ami
proche
je me trouve la vie avec une amie proche
mais n'arrivera jamais à judas non non
on fait tout mon là bas les restos les
matches aller les bons plans les quarts
sans visage doit jamais découvrir naglaa
ouais
gros deal avec qui comme ami proche
s'est pas encore quelqu'un allait proche
proche le ba ba wind prospect
pareil et guillaume frisquet
[Rires]